i set the trends i don't follow them
what's up y'all what's happening it's
big lotto and you're watching on the
rocks
[Music]
lotto is short for the lottery and it
just means like the jackpot in 777 for
me it's not just financially hitting a
jackpot it's just hitting the jackpot in
life like i'm winning i'm over blessed
my favorite piece is probably this right
here lately i've been into the more like
dainty stuff like this one was a
valentine's day gift inside of here
which y'all not gonna get to see is like
hammer in the letter and a picture and
it just made me cry and it's just so
sweet and sentimental that's probably my
favorite anything that thing you see
that stone in the middle baby she wears
something
gucci probably is the main reason why as
soon as i signed that deal i went and
got the biggest [ __ ] that i could get
gucci got that big ass like ice daddy or
something like that gucci is definitely
an influence but i ain't on that number
i can
i have not bought a pendant and i don't
see myself buying no penny because i was
like oh new album i should probably get
777 pending but i was like i don't
[ __ ] want no 777 penny like if
anything i would get like something cute
like this
i do also got love for this piece right
here this was my first chain i ever
bought maybe i bought this chain when i
was like 18 from waffy she might look
like but she heavy baby that was
probably like 15 000 and i was only 18
maybe dropping them racks
yeah
my most expensive piece is
she from icebox i got her as a birthday
gift to myself like 120 like a little
over a hundred but she worth it like
when i feel like really flexing i'm
bringing her out seven is my lucky
number it's god's number tripled is just
like unbeatable i'm god's shopping we
don't play that so 777 over here it
became a part of my brand when i changed
my name for me it's like hitting a
jackpot in life period not just
financially this chain is heavy like no
cap i'd be scared to perform with that
that pendant would knock a tooth out
chip or two something these veneers is
like pearly white he's like these this
they cost a pretty penny too so you know
what i'm saying we ain't trying to chip
these this one right here is my new baby
i'll take this pendant off and put it on
this chain these these two be competing
because they both just hold such special
meaning for me when i got this i cried
like a baby because it's a picture of me
and i have a microphone in my hand and
then the other it's swirls and the other
side is my mom holding me at her high
school graduation she got it out the mud
and that's where i get my hustle
mentality from she really touched my
heart i was mad at her i wanted like
girl don't spend your money on me like
let me buy the jury i'm the rapper but
my mom got that bad tuna so
she liked to spoil me too i was mad at
first but when i seen a bag
from waffy i got mad but then i seen
what it was and i just cried like a baby
like this was literally just a week ago
the big lotto pendant she was my first i
got her when i got this ap i got them
both at the same time that was like my
first set of like big jewelry like
rapper jewelry i got big lotto when i
signed to rca and then i got this ap
custom with the pink arabic numbers i
probably spent
40 42 something like that i wear it in
music videos like y'all seen it in the
movie she gets her little uh cameos
every now and then but she's definitely
not an everyday my favorite watch i'm
wearing her right now she's my rich
millie this was one of my birthday gifts
this year she's baby pink and she buzzed
down it's probably my favorite one
because this is just a flex like period
but then recently i got this plain ap
for valentine's day it's so cute um
because she could see if this didn't
cost what it cost it this would this
would be my favorite watch you can't
have a richer and it not be your
favorite watch this just don't even make
sense this is my favorite watch by
default but this is really my favorite
watch like i wear this every day she
don't get old she's just timeless my
first watch was a bust down roll it this
was my first like expensive expensive
watch my bus down rolex was probably
like 10 12 000 i bought that when i was
19
then i got this i paid like 40 for that
watch this one was my ap skelly bust
down here to my lyrics i rap about her
all the time it don't get no better ap
than this it's like top of the ap
my wrist is dainty like i don't even
need no big ass men's watch like if i
wear a bus die it's gonna be this one i
don't even really do that one no more
like
my bracelets really i accumulated all of
these at once i woke up and i went to
waffy and i was like
i need some bracelets and i spent like
a little over a hundred but a lot of
times i just wear these by themselves
some of them is like get inside and
stuff so this ain't nothing that's what
i'm saying like i need this in a
negative swimming bay if you watch it i
need this and the necklace one okay
the cheapest one is probably like five
thousand the most expensive one is
probably the one my men by me and i
don't even know where to go atlanta
being like rapper central every [ __ ]
rapper is in atlanta or lives in atlanta
it's a lot of like gotti
layer your chains wear a ring on every
finger bracelets to your elbow and stuff
like that so that's probably what
inspired me to wake up and go get all
them damn rings and bracelets one day
cause i was just like damn i need to
catch up
i used to really really be obsessed with
cubans because they like big and icy
whatever but now i like them the smaller
stuff like just the emerald chain i need
to get like a like a tennis like a
chunky pointer tennis like so i don't
even be wearing my pendants like that no
more too many people got this [ __ ] now i
just it's not exciting no more like it
used to be i actually really love my
rings i'm not gonna lie like i got them
probably like a year ago these are the
ones i wear the big heart one she is
seen on stage i might see her on stage
or whatever but for the most part i'm
wearing my tulip bins my simple bands
it's just it's show like i know she got
money i don't even got to see her
jewelry collection because i know she
got something sent in her box at home
she don't even wear it like that's what
they give like artists don't go wasting
money because you're going to be like me
a couple years later and be like damn i
just got all this [ __ ] i don't even
[ __ ] wear it don't let all that like
hype and the trends let you go broke now
i got the money to spend on this [ __ ]
don't go broke trying to impress people
that don't matter
thanks gq for letting me show y'all my
collection 777 the album out now go get
it